2023, 2023. Happy New Year, Happy New Year, Happy New Year. Is it 23 or is it 22? It's 23. Welcome. I've been here for a minute and I just want to welcome you guys. I was waiting for you guys to get here. Cool, right? It's pretty cool. It seems, feels a little bit like last year, but... No, it's way different. Also, the episodes are way different too. It's so insane. Come on, join me. Welcome to Smart Less. Smart.
2023年，2023年。新年快乐，新年快乐，新年快乐。现在是23年还是22年？是23年。欢迎。我来这儿一会儿了，我只是想欢迎你们。我一直在等你们过来。很酷，对吧？挺酷的。看起来，感觉有点像去年，但是……不，完全不同。而且，剧集也完全不同。太疯狂了。来吧，加入我。欢迎来到《SmartLess》。Smart。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Yeah, hi, guys. Hey. Sean and I were just, I'm getting down a late breakfast here with the oatmeal.
Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。是的，嗨，伙计们。嘿。肖恩和我刚才，我正在这儿吃燕麦片当迟到的早餐。
He doesn't. It's so disgusting. He says he doesn't. Listen, sloppy Joe, you eat the worst crap in the world, and you won't eat oatmeal? No, when I was really young, I had issues about being so thin. And like, you know, I think we mentioned this before. I used to get made fun of for being super skinny. Right.
他才不吃。太恶心了。他说他不吃。听着，邋遢乔，你吃的是世界上最烂的垃圾，你竟然不吃燕麦片？不，我小时候，因为太瘦而有些困扰。而且，你知道，我想我们之前提到过。我以前因为太瘦而被人取笑。没错。
And so I would eat tons of oatmeal and milkshakes and ice cream and burgers. And I couldn't gain. Oatmeal doesn't make you fat. No, but oatmeal had a lot of protein in it. So I was trying to like gain weight and muscle weight and all that. But I just couldn't handle it. But it's so good. Let's take a look.
所以我以前会吃大量的燕麦片、奶昔、冰淇淋和汉堡。但我就是长不胖。燕麦片不会让你变胖。不，但燕麦片里有很多蛋白质。所以我当时是想增加体重、肌肉重量之类的。但我就是受不了。但这东西很好吃。让我们看看。
Let's take a look in that bowl again. Let's just look at it. It would help clean out all of the garbage you put in your system, Sean. I know that's true. You know, you get like that little bike license plate out of you. You know,
让我们再看看那个碗。就看一眼。它有助于清理你体内所有的垃圾，肖恩。我知道那是真的。你知道，你就像那个小自行车牌照一样。你知道，
that says eight wheeler on it. What do you usually have for breakfast? Do you, are you a breakfast guy? Well, remember last time I said I had chili and cornbread? Oh, right, right. But usually, because I never really eat breakfast. I usually wait until, like, lunch to eat something,
上面写着“八轮驱动”。你通常早餐吃什么？你，你是那种吃早餐的人吗？嗯，还记得上次我说我吃了辣椒和玉米面包吗？哦，对，对。但通常，因为我从来不怎么吃早餐。我通常等到午餐才吃点东西，
and then I'll eat, like, you know, like, tuna fish sandwich or whatever. So that's kind of my breakfast. Willie, you're not a breakfast guy, are you? No, it depends. Sometimes on the weekend I am. I'm a late morning little snack. And will you cook up a breakfast for the kids? Are you one of those guys?
然后我会吃，你知道，比如金枪鱼三明治之类的。所以那算是我的早餐。威利，你不是那种吃早餐的人，对吧？不，看情况。有时候周末我会吃。我会在上午晚些时候吃点小零食。你会给孩子们做早餐吗？你是那种人吗？
I don't usually cook up, like, school day. They don't want breakfast now because they're older in the morning before school, so they'll have, like, toast. Well, we FaceTimed last week at 10 o'clock at night and Abel was in the background. Eating cereal.
我通常不会做，比如上学日。他们现在不想吃早餐，因为他们早上上学前已经长大了，所以他们会吃点吐司之类的。嗯，我们上周晚上10点视频通话，阿贝尔就在背景里。在吃麦片。
And I'm like, Abel, what are you eating? He's like, cereal. Yeah. At 10 o'clock at night. I love cereal at night. I love cereal. They both do, both the kids, we eat dinner so early,
我说，阿贝尔，你在吃什么？他说，麦片。是的。在晚上10点。我喜欢晚上吃麦片。我喜欢麦片。他们两个都喜欢，两个孩子，我们吃晚饭太早了，
so both of the older kids generally hit that thing where at about 8, 9 o'clock they get real snacky. But will you worry about them going to school without food? Like, I've always got like a power bar for the girls in the car going to school, making sure they got something. I always make sure that they eat something at home.
所以两个大一点的孩子通常在8、9点左右会变得特别想吃零食。但你会担心他们没吃东西就去上学吗？比如，我车里总是给女孩们准备能量棒，去学校的路上吃，确保她们吃点东西。我总是确保她们在家里吃点东西。
They sit at the counter and eat something at home before they go. Usually like a cereal yogurt with granola or some kind of a cereal or a toast. Or a sugary cereal. I've seen your pantry. Yeah. Yeah, I know you've seen my, but I think you have the wrong impression.
她们坐在柜台前，在去学校前在家里吃点东西。通常是加了格兰诺拉麦片的酸奶，或者某种麦片，或者吐司。或者含糖麦片。我见过你的储藏室。是的。是的，我知道你见过我的，但我认为你印象错了。
It's envy. Wrong impression? So when I'm looking at Frosted Flakes, it's not really Frosted Flakes? No, because like for instance, the Frosted Flakes that you're referring to have been in that container. No, not three boxes.
那是嫉妒。印象错了？所以当我看到磨砂玉米片时，那不是真的磨砂玉米片？不，因为比如，你提到的磨砂玉米片一直都在那个容器里。不，不是三盒。
At all. And have been there for so long. This is just above the Oreos, right? It's just above the three different kinds of Oreos? By the way, the Oreos are in those little packages. And they were, again, they were for the kids for school. They were snacks. I can't remember the last time I saw somebody in this house eating Oreos.
根本不是。而且在那儿放了很久了。这就在奥利奥饼干上面，对吧？就在那三种不同的奥利奥上面？顺便说一下，奥利奥在那些小包装里。它们，再说一次，是给孩子们上学准备的。它们是零食。我不记得上次看到家里有人吃奥利奥是什么时候了。
I think it was you when you came in and grabbed them. Yeah, well, I've run into your pantry. This is my first stop because we have, you know, oats and barley and quinoa at this house, which I love, but I do like to shake it up every once in a while. I love it. Remember when we had dinner a while ago, Jay, and I said, before I come over, can Amanda please get me a Coca-Cola?
我想是你进来抓走它们的时候。是的，好吧，我闯进过你的储藏室。这是我的第一站，因为我们家有燕麦、大麦和藜麦，我喜欢这些，但我确实喜欢偶尔换换口味。我喜欢。还记得前阵子我们吃晚饭时，杰，我说，在我过去之前，阿曼达能帮我拿一瓶可口可乐吗？
Yeah, I think she did. She bought a few of them. Yeah. All right. Listen. Yeah. I'm pulling up my – listen Yeah. I'm pulling up my... Listen up. I'm pulling up my...
是的，我想她拿了。她买了几瓶。是的。好吧。听着。是的。我正在拿出我的——听着，是的。我正在拿出我的……听着。我正在拿出我的……
I spent some time on this intro here. This is your guest. Yeah. This is not some silly guest. Tighten up. Today we've got a guest that is the closest thing to a magician that we've ever had. Okay? Well, he doesn't pull bunnies out of hats or miraculously saw women in half. He is able to magically take us into environments and experiences that not only feel and look real, but they manage to access our most protected and personal places of thought and emotion. He does this with incredible writing, extraordinary images, and raw performances.
我花了一些时间准备这段开场白。这是你们的嘉宾。是的。这不是什么愚蠢的嘉宾。打起精神来。今天我们请到了一位嘉宾，他简直就是我们请过的最接近魔术师的人。好吗？嗯，他不会从帽子里变出兔子，也不会奇迹般地把女人锯成两半。他能够神奇地把我们带入那些不仅看起来真实，而且还能触及我们内心最隐秘、最私人的思想和情感的境地和体验。他通过令人难以置信的写作、非凡的影像和原始的表演做到了这一点。
He has received five Academy Awards, including Best Director in Back-to-Back Years. Only the third person ever do that. He's the youngest of seven kids. He was kicked out of high school. He became a radio DJ. He became a cargo boat sailor. He eventually found a camera to play with. And thank God, because this man has brought us some of the best films ever made. Films like Babel, Birdman, The Revenant, and his latest and perhaps greatest, Bardo. Please welcome one of my heroes, Alejandro Iñárritu. No way.
他获得了五项奥斯卡奖，包括连续两年获得最佳导演奖。历史上只有第三个人做到这一点。他是七个孩子中最小的一个。他被高中开除了。他当过电台DJ。他当过货船水手。他最终找到了一台相机来玩。感谢上帝，因为这个人给我们带来了有史以来最好的一些电影。像《通天塔》、《鸟人》、《荒野猎人》，以及他最新、或许也是最伟大的作品《诗人》。请欢迎我的英雄之一，亚历杭德罗·伊纳里图。不会吧。
Alejandro? How are you guys? Good morning. Hello. Good morning. Yes. Oh, my God. We're going to class it up today.
亚历杭德罗？你们好吗？早上好。你好。早上好。是的。天哪。我们今天要把档次提高一下。
You really classed it up. Right? This is incredible. These guys, they can't. I've never heard them so quiet. They're stunned. I know. I was like, the second you started naming the films,
你真的把档次提高了。对吧？这太不可思议了。这些家伙，他们不能。我从来没听过他们这么安静。他们惊呆了。我知道。我当时想，你开始列举电影名字的那一秒，
I was like, are you kidding me? Yeah, you thought it was a joke. So I saw Bardo last night, and it truly is, I think, given even with all the films that you've done, it could be your best. Do you feel like, I think I've read something where you said that you think it might be your best and that's saying something.
我就想，你在开玩笑吗？是的，你以为那是开玩笑。所以我昨晚看了《诗人》，我认为它确实是，即使考虑到你拍过的所有电影，它也可能是你最好的一部。你觉得，我想我读到过一些东西，你说你认为它可能是你最好的作品，这可不简单。
Well, first of all, thank you for that incredible, generous introduction that you gave. I can't wait. This is our strategy though. We build you up and then we're going to hit you with some really embarrassing questions. And I was just like having a hungry, just listening to you about the breakfast.
嗯，首先，谢谢你那令人难以置信、慷慨的介绍。我等不及了。不过这是我们的策略。我们先把你捧高，然后我们要用一些非常尴尬的问题来打击你。我刚才听你说早餐的时候，简直饿坏了。
About breakfast. I have some chilaquiles, guys. That's the Mexican way to go in the morning. Chilaquiles are in your movie. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. Chilaquiles and frijoles.
关于早餐。我有一些墨西哥玉米片，伙计们。那是墨西哥人早上的首选。墨西哥玉米片在你的电影里。是的。没错。没错。墨西哥玉米片和豆子。
So what do you think? Do you think Bardo's your best? It's a big statement. You know, the thing is, what I felt about Bardo and I feel about Bardo is that I think it's the film that I have spent
所以你怎么看？你认为《诗人》是你最好的作品吗？这是一个很大的声明。你知道，问题是，关于《诗人》，我的感受是，我认为这是我花了
much more time with cooking it you know preparing it and conceiving it and then all the things that I have learned I think that technically and how to say things, the material or the fabric of this film was very complex.
更多时间去烹饪、准备和构思的电影，然后我所学到的一切，我认为在技术上以及如何表达事物方面，这部电影的材料或结构非常复杂。
So I was very happy just to have made it, you know, that I could turn that thing into something. And that's why I consider that, yeah, I think it's my, you know, the film that I felt that I have accomplished in a better way or in a much more honest way close to my heart. You know, that's why I consider it that. You felt that maybe you asked yourself to bring everything that you have learned thus far technically and also, I mean, emotionally and spiritually. I mean, it is. So just for you, Sean and Will, and also the listeners, Bardo is, and I had to look this up, it is a, and correct me if I'm wrong, Alejandro, it is a Tibetan phrase that means or describes the place post-death and pre-rebirth or reincarnation.
所以我很高兴能把它做出来，你知道，我能把它变成某种东西。这就是为什么我认为，是的，我认为这是我，你知道，我感觉我以一种更好的方式，或者以一种更诚实、更贴近我内心的方式完成的电影。你知道，这就是为什么我这么认为。你觉得也许你要求自己把你迄今为止学到的一切，在技术上，还有情感上和精神上都带入其中。我的意思是，确实如此。所以，肖恩和威尔，还有听众们，《诗人》是，我不得不查了一下，它是一个，如果我说错了请纠正我，亚历杭德罗，它是一个藏语短语，意思是或描述了死后和重生或轮回之前的那个地方。
So it's sort of that, some people call it... Purgatory? Yeah, thank you. Purgatory or, well, Purgatory is a place between heaven and hell, I think. But so the film spends a lot of time or toggles back and forth between what could be real or could be this nether place, or I don't think that that's spoiling anything
所以它有点像，有些人称之为……炼狱？是的，谢谢。炼狱或者，嗯，炼狱是天堂和地狱之间的一个地方，我想。但这部电影花了很多时间在什么是真实的，或者可能是什么阴间的地方之间来回切换，或者我不认为这算剧透，
alejandro i hope it's not but um it obviously lends itself to a lot of filmmaking techniques uh both visually i can't wait to see this so in just sort of the the the storylines of things uh it's it's it's very very beautifully uh complex uh not not, not difficult, but just so rewarding. It does ask of you everything that you've learned, certainly, it seems. Yeah, well, thank you. Thank you very much for that, Jason. Yeah, exactly. I mean, you know, basically in the Catholic tradition is kind of what we know as limbo,
亚历杭德罗，我希望不是，但它显然非常适合运用许多电影制作技术，呃，在视觉上，我迫不及待想看到这个，所以就故事线而言，它非常非常美丽地，呃，复杂，呃，不是，不是困难，只是非常有回报。它确实要求你付出你所学到的一切，当然，看起来是这样。是的，好吧，谢谢。非常感谢你，杰森。是的，没错。我的意思是，你知道，基本上在天主教传统中，这就是我们所知的灵薄狱，
which is that kind of purgatory where little kids that are not baptized, they go after if they die. But it's a very narrow kind of conception. And Bardo in the Buddhist tradition is exactly that. When something dies, you know, something is transforming to another place, but it's in the between, you know. It's exactly in the middle point before to becoming something. And that's kind of the concept of that word, the way I wanted to use it. Yeah, it's so exciting.
也就是那种炼狱，没有受洗的小孩如果死了就会去那里。但这是一种非常狭隘的概念。而在佛教传统中，《诗人》正是如此。当某物死亡时，你知道，某物正在转化为另一个地方，但它处于中间，你知道。它正好处于变成某物之前的中间点。这就是那个词的概念，我想要使用它的方式。是的，太令人兴奋了。
As a viewer, you never know whether it is current time or a flashback or real or imagined or dreamscape or not. Do you remember the Adrian Line film, guys, Jacob's Ladder? Sure, yeah. Where it's basically about, you don't know until the end that where we have been is on this guy's deathbed. He's sort of purgatory. But it allows the film to travel in so many crazy spaces.
作为观众，你永远不知道它是当前时间，还是闪回，还是真实的，还是想象的，还是梦境。你们记得阿德里安·莱恩的电影《异世浮生》吗，伙计们？当然，是的。基本上讲的是，直到最后你才知道我们所处的地方是在这个家伙的临终病床上。他处于某种炼狱中。但这让电影可以在许多疯狂的空间中穿梭。
And talk to me a little bit about the writing process of that, the not only putting in all of your, you know, clearly deeply felt emotional places, but also playing with time and the complexity of the nonlinear aspect. You're constantly flashing forwards or back or real or unreal. Was that difficult or was it simple for you? aspect you're constantly flashing forwards or back or or real or unreal was that was that difficult or was it simple for you no actually i think was one of the most um challenging things i will say and scary because there was no recipe you know because structurally you know in the film you can play very well with flashbacks or flash heads andeads, and they are very, I would say, constructed in a way
跟我谈谈那部电影的写作过程，不仅是投入你所有，你知道，显然是深切感受到的情感空间，而且还玩弄时间和非线性方面的复杂性。你不断地闪前或闪后，或者真实或不真实。这很难吗，还是对你来说很简单？方面你不断地闪前或闪后，或者真实或不真实，那，那很难吗，还是对你来说很简单？不，实际上我认为这是最，呃，具有挑战性的事情之一，我会说，而且很可怕，因为没有食谱，你知道，因为在结构上，你知道，在电影中你可以很好地运用闪回或闪前，它们非常，我会说，以一种方式构建，
that they are very, in a way, immediately you recognize that the film has shifted or traveled to another thing. You can use different photography or different things to point out that kind of thing. So these are more conventional narratives or grammatical ways that you can use in filmmaking. And I think I love that film, by the way. I haven't seen it in a long time.
以至于它们非常，在某种程度上，你立刻就能认出电影已经转移或旅行到了另一件事上。你可以使用不同的摄影或不同的东西来指出那种事情。所以这些是电影制作中更传统的叙事或语法方式。而且我认为我喜欢那部电影，顺便说一下。我已经很久没看了。
Now you're going to see it again. I remember Jacob's Ladder was amazing with Tim Robbins, right? Yeah, yeah. It was Tim Robbins. But in this case, the challenge was this film, Bardo, is a walk in the consciousness of somebody, right? Which is all memories and images and reflections and thoughts and emotions
现在你要再看一遍了。我记得《异世浮生》很棒，蒂姆·罗宾斯主演，对吧？是的，是的。是蒂姆·罗宾斯。但在这种情况下，挑战在于这部电影，《诗人》，是一个人意识中的漫步，对吧？所有的记忆、图像、反思、思想和情感
are basically interacting simultaneously and coexisting in the way when we dream, you know, and we are, you know, when you have a lucid dream, that you are aware that you are dreaming, you know that things are off or some person is in a place that should not be there. Or maybe you are in your uncle's house, but one guy is there and then the house becomes something else in your garden. And you have a little bit of control over it too sometimes in a dream, right?
基本上都在同时互动并共存，就像我们做梦时那样，你知道，当我们，你知道，当你做清醒梦时，你意识到你在做梦，你知道事情不对劲，或者某个人出现在他不该出现的地方。或者也许你在你叔叔家，但一个人在那儿，然后房子在你的花园里变成了别的东西。而且你在梦里有时也有点控制力，对吧？
Like you do in this film. Well, you know, really quick, a super quick story about jimmy burroughs you know james burroughs all under he's he's a tv director friend of ours um i was in new york and uh i just flown there i was super super super tired from working all week and then the flight and everything i laid down for a nap in the hotel and in my dream uh our sweet friend jimmy burrow something he was like having a heart attack or something in my dream i was like oh no i gotta help him i gotta help him so i pick up the you know in the dream i'm like i'm dialing 911 i call the ambulance everybody comes it's so freaky and then the hotel phone rings and it wakes
就像你在电影里做的那样。嗯，你知道，很快，关于吉米·伯罗斯的一个超级快的故事，你知道詹姆斯·伯罗斯，亚历杭德罗，他是我们的电视导演朋友，我在纽约，我刚飞到那儿，我工作了一整周，加上飞行，我累得要命，我在酒店躺下小睡，在梦里，我们亲爱的朋友吉米·伯罗斯，他好像心脏病发作了，在梦里我心想，哦不，我得帮他，我得帮他，所以我拿起，在梦里我拨打911，我叫了救护车，每个人都来了，太诡异了，然后酒店电话响了，把我从午睡中吵醒了，我接起电话说喂，他们说是的，911，你有什么紧急情况？所以我打了，哇，在你睡觉的时候，在我睡觉的时候，但这看起来就像梦游，是的，我以前从来没发生过这种事，这不是很棒吗？是的，呃，梦是一个不可思议的地方，我想我们，我们刚刚，我们刚刚在播客上请到了詹姆斯·卡梅隆，亚历杭德罗，我想我们对他说，他会是一位不可思议的电影制作人，你也是，去处理梦境，去拍一部关于梦境的电影，这需要像你或他这样有技巧的人来处理这一切，这对电影来说是一个丰富的地方，呃，好吧，所以，呃，你的电影，呃，非常受益于你的视觉策略。
me up for my nap and i go hello and they say yeah 9-1-1 what's your emergency so i called wow while you were while you were sleeping while i was sleeping but it seems so like sleepwalking yeah isn't it great that i've never that's never happened to me before yeah it's uh dreams are an incredible place i think we we just had we had uh uh james cameron on uh on the podcast the other day uh alondra and i think we said to him he would be an incredible filmmaker as would you to tackle dreams to to to do a film about dreams it would take somebody of of your skill or his to to tackle all that it's a a rich place for for a film um all right so um you your films uh benefit so much from your visual strategy.
你能追溯到那一点吗？你肯定不是在你短暂的电台生涯中学会的，对吧？你从哪里得到那种对视觉的品味和技术知识的？我会说我还在努力学习很多。我认为我的向导一直是音乐。你知道，我认为我有更好的耳朵。我试着先去听电影，并确定它是什么类型的电影。
Can you trace that back? You certainly didn't learn that in your brief radio career, did you? Where did you get that taste for visuals and the technical know-how of it? I will say that I'm still trying to learn a lot. I think my guide always has been music. You know, I think I have a better ear. And I try to first kind of listen to the film and kind of determine what kind of genre it is
你能追溯一下吗？你肯定不是在你短暂的广播生涯中学到的，对吧？你对视觉的品味和相关的技术知识是从哪里来的？我得说我还在努力学习很多东西。我认为我的向导一直都是音乐。你知道，我觉得我的听觉更好。我试着先去听这部电影，然后确定它属于什么类型。
and what is the rhythm and the sound and the beat. And then the question that I have been much more always is challenging for me is the point of view you know the which point of view I would like to be putting the audience and that is what really makes me decide how I'm going to shoot so those two things really helped me to understand how I want the audience to live the experience because I would like them to live depending in the point of view, which sometimes get complicated when you have two, three characters or four characters in a scene. So you want to have the, you know, to receive or to land the emotional kind of challenge of a scene in somebody's. And that is always a tough question for me that I have to answer.
还有节奏、声音和节拍。对我来说，一直以来最具挑战性的问题是视角，你知道，我想把观众置于哪个视角，这才是真正决定我如何拍摄的关键。所以这两点确实帮助我理解了我想让观众如何去体验，因为我希望他们能根据视角去感受，而当一个场景中有两、三个甚至四个角色时，这有时会变得很复杂。你想让观众接收到或感受到某个场景中某个人物的情感冲击。对我来说，这始终是一个必须回答的难题。
And then I decide where I put the camera and how open. And then about the context, because in the first films I did, I normally tend to isolate the characters. And I was very keen into the close-ups, which I think is an incredible landscape to show everything and emotional and everything what's going on. But then little by little in the last three films, I have been very obsessed about the context of the character. You know, what really make that character a character? And so then I have been trying to involve more and more the context of the situation.
然后我决定把摄像机放在哪里，以及取景的广度。关于背景，因为在我拍的前几部电影里，我通常倾向于孤立角色。我非常热衷于特写镜头，我认为那是一个展现一切、展现情感以及发生的一切的绝佳景观。但后来，在最近的三部电影中，我逐渐开始痴迷于角色的背景。你知道，是什么真正造就了那个角色？所以我一直在尝试越来越多地融入情境背景。
And I have been now rejecting every lens that is more than 21. I felt that it's like a long lens. You know what I feel like? Yeah, yeah. We'll be right back. SmartLess is brought to you in part by Airbnb. Okay. We all know Sean.
我现在已经拒绝使用任何超过21毫米的镜头了。我觉得那就像长焦镜头。你知道我的意思吗？是啊，是啊。我们马上回来。SmartLess节目由Airbnb部分赞助。好了，大家都认识肖恩。
We love him. He's a great guy. Sean Hayes. From the TV and the films and the Smart List podcast. But guess what? Sean Hayes, he's got a big family reunion coming up, and he has booked an Airbnb for his family. Sick idea. That's so good. How can you figure out a way to get everybody together in
我们爱他。他是个很棒的人。肖恩·海耶斯。来自电视、电影和SmartLess播客。但你猜怎么着？肖恩·海耶斯，他有一个大型家庭聚会要举行，他为家人预订了一家Airbnb。太棒的主意了。太好了。你怎么能想出办法把大家聚在一起呢？
one place? The best way to do it is to get an Airbnb. Maybe you've stayed in an Airbnb before and thought to yourself, this actually seems pretty doable. Maybe my place could be an Airbnb. It could be as simple as starting with a spare room or your whole place when you're away. as starting with a spare room or your whole place when you're away. You could be sitting on an Airbnb and not even know it. Maybe you're planning a ski getaway this winter. While you're away,
最好的办法就是找一家Airbnb。也许你以前住过Airbnb，心里想过，这其实挺可行的。也许我的房子也可以成为Airbnb。这可以很简单，从一个空余房间开始，或者当你不在家时出租整个房子。你可能坐拥一家Airbnb却浑然不知。也许你正计划今年冬天去滑雪度假。当你不在家时，
you could Airbnb your home and make some extra money toward the trip. Whether you could use extra money to cover some bills or for something a little more fun, your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at airbnb.ca slash host. SmartLess is brought to you in part by Rakuten.
你可以把你的家放到Airbnb上出租，赚点外快来补贴旅费。无论你是想用这笔钱支付账单，还是想做点更有趣的事情，你的家可能比你想象的更有价值。访问 airbnb.ca/host 了解详情。SmartLess节目由Rakuten部分赞助。
Think of the last time you bought something to wear, something to decorate your house, something for your family or friends. What if each time you made a purchase, you got a little something back? With Rakuten, you can. You can earn cash back on just about anything you buy from over 750 stores. If you've ever bought electronics, home decor, fashion, and beauty, or booked a trip, well, you could have gotten cash back. But don't worry, it's not too late. It's free and easy to use, and you get cash back deposited in your PayPal account or sent to you as a check. Earn cash back at stores like Sephora, Old Navy, and Expedia. It's the smartest way to shop, plain and simple. Start your shopping
想想你上次买衣服、装饰房子、为家人或朋友买东西的时候。如果每次购物都能得到一点回馈会怎样？有了Rakuten，你就可以。你在超过750家商店购买的几乎任何东西都可以获得现金返还。如果你曾经购买过电子产品、家居装饰、时尚美妆，或者预订过旅行，那么你本可以获得现金返还。别担心，现在还不晚。它免费且易于使用，现金返还会存入你的PayPal账户或以支票形式寄给你。在丝芙兰、Old Navy和Expedia等商店赚取现金返还。这是最聪明的购物方式，简单明了。开始购物
at Rakuten.ca or get the Rakuten app. That's R-A-K-U-T-E-N. Hi, I'm Anna. And I'm Emily. We're the hosts of Wanderers Podcast Terribly Famous, a show where we bring you outrageous true stories about our most famous celebrities. And our latest season is all about the one and only Katie Price. You might think you know her, you might have an opinion,
访问 Rakuten.ca 或下载 Rakuten 应用程序。即 R-A-K-U-T-E-N。嗨，我是安娜。我是艾米丽。我们是Wondery播客《Terribly Famous》的主持人，在这个节目中，我们会为你讲述关于我们最著名名人的离奇真实故事。我们最新一季的主角是独一无二的凯蒂·普莱斯。你可能以为你了解她，你可能有自己的看法，
but there is way more to the former glamour model than just her cup size. Yes, this is a woman who's gone from pin-up to publishing sensation. We all have teenage dreams, and for Katie it was simple, massive fame and everlasting love. I just wanted to kiss a boy just one boy. Well she does kiss a few boys but there are plenty of bumps along the way and when I say bumps I mean terrible boyfriend choices, secret dates with spiky haired pop stars and a tabloid press that wants to tear her apart at every opportunity. And she surprises even herself
但这位前魅力模特远不止她的罩杯那么简单。是的，这是一个从海报女郎变成出版界轰动人物的女性。我们都有青春梦想，对凯蒂来说很简单，就是巨大的名声和永恒的爱。我只是想吻一个男孩，就一个男孩。好吧，她确实吻过几个男孩，但这一路走来有很多坎坷，我说的坎坷是指糟糕的男友选择、与刺头流行歌星的秘密约会，以及那些想方设法要把她撕碎的小报媒体。甚至连她自己都感到惊讶，
when suddenly she becomes a role model for a whole new generation of young women who want to be just like her. Want to hear more? Follow Terribly Famous wherever you listen to podcasts or listen early and add free on Wondery Plus on Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. And now back to the show. Can I talk to you a little bit about, because it's funny you say that because I forget, And now, back to the show. Can I talk to you a little bit about, because it's funny you say that, because I forget, we were talking to somebody,
当她突然成为新一代年轻女性的榜样，她们都想变得像她一样。想听更多吗？在任何你收听播客的地方关注《Terribly Famous》，或者在Apple Podcasts或Wondery应用程序上的Wondery Plus提前收听无广告版。现在回到节目。我可以和你聊聊吗，因为你说得很有趣，因为我忘了，我们当时在和某人交谈，
but I think we were talking to a director about it, about this idea of, if you look at a lot of those films from the 70s, like even Spielberg in the 70s, one thing that comes to mind is like Close Encounters. So many of those scenes played with virtually no coverage at all. Right. And everybody's talking over each other.
但我认为我们是在和一位导演讨论这个问题，关于这个想法：如果你看看70年代的那些电影，比如70年代的斯皮尔伯格，脑海中浮现的一件事就是《第三类接触》。很多场景几乎没有任何覆盖镜头。没错。而且每个人都在抢话。
Everybody's talking over each other, and you had these scenes that played out in these big sort of, you know, almost masters, and sometimes, you know, characters would come in and out of the scene. Robert Altman did a lot of that, and Woody Allen. Yeah, and then Robert Altman did that as well. And so that you got to talk about context. I mean, you got to kind of see so much of the world.
每个人都在抢话，你看到的这些场景都是以那种大型的、你知道的，几乎是主镜头的方式呈现的，有时角色会进出场景。罗伯特·奥特曼做了很多这样的尝试，伍迪·艾伦也是。是的，罗伯特·奥特曼也做过。所以你得谈谈背景。我的意思是，你得能看到这个世界的很大一部分。
And we've become, and not to get too deep in the woods, in the weeds on this, but do you feel like we've become too, I think, for my taste, too dependent on close-ups? Especially when you come to things like comedy. Yeah. Because it ends up, I love seeing two, at least two characters in the same frame together reacting off each other in a way that doesn't feel like
我们已经变得——不是要深陷其中——但你觉得我们是否变得太依赖特写镜头了？尤其是当你涉及到喜剧这类题材时。是的。因为最终，我喜欢在同一个画面中看到至少两个角色在一起，他们之间的互动方式不会让你觉得
you're telling me how I should be reacting to this. You allow the scene to play out and I can decide for myself what I feel about the story and their relationship. Yes, I think you're right. I think you're right. I think like if you see Billy Wilder, for example, comedies, he always was like really much more relaxed and the things were happening in front of you. And as you said, the characters come close to the camera
你在告诉我我应该对此有什么反应。你让场景自然展开，我可以自己决定对故事和他们关系的感受。是的，我想你是对的。我想你是对的。比如如果你看比利·怀尔德的喜剧，他总是非常放松，事情就在你面前发生。正如你所说，角色靠近摄像机
or further, and that is kind of the blocking of that. And Spielberg is the master of blocking actors, I think. Staging, right? Staging is just so so incredible i think he's the best in the world yeah well i feel the same way like whenever there's like a a film about like dance or like i'm watching like a cheerleading thing on espn or whatever we're like the camera like if you go in close to watch a whole dance number it's like no i can't see the whole The whole point of a dance number
或者远离，这就是那种调度。我认为斯皮尔伯格是演员调度的大师。舞台调度，对吧？舞台调度真是太不可思议了，我认为他是世界上最好的。是的，我也这么觉得。就像每当有关于舞蹈的电影，或者我在ESPN上看啦啦队表演之类的，如果摄像机为了看清整个舞蹈动作而拉得太近，我就想，不，我看不全。整个舞蹈动作的意义
is to see everybody doing it at the same time. So that it's five, six... Seven, eight. And not cut to seven, eight. You want to see five, six, seven, eight in the same frame. No, but I do. I think that that's true.
在于看到所有人同时在做。所以是五、六……七、八。而不是切到七、八。你想在同一个画面里看到五、六、七、八。不，但我确实这么认为。我认为那是真的。
And I think that we have been... You know, it's so funny when you go and you work. Alejandro, my experience as an actor, certainly, is when you go and you work. Alejandro, my experience as an actress, certainly, is when you go and you work on stuff, people are so scared and everybody's so nervous now of protect. So it's always like for protection. Well, we're just going to do... So that when I go and do stuff on my own
而且我认为我们一直……你知道，当你去工作时，这太有趣了。亚历杭德罗，我作为演员的经验，当然，当你去工作时，人们非常害怕，每个人现在都对保护镜头感到非常紧张。所以总是为了“保险”。好吧，我们只是要做……所以当我独自做事情时
and I go where I'm kind of the boss or I'm running the show or whatever, and they'll go like, well, we should get the other thing. I go, no, no, no, I'm never of the boss or I'm running the show or whatever. And they'll go like, well, we should get the other thing. I go, no, no, no, I'm never going to use it. Well, shouldn't we get just to have it? I go, no, I don't give a shit. I'm never going to use it.
当我处于主导地位或负责节目时，他们会说，好吧，我们应该拍点别的。我说，不，不，不，我永远不会用它。好吧，我们不应该为了以防万一拍一下吗？我说，不，我不在乎。我永远不会用它。
Fucking I know how I'm going to cut it and I don't give a shit. Well, I think it would be really important. And you want to be like, to you. Yeah, and the one shot, the one-er is is is super good for that right um you use that a lot right with it you don't even you don't even give yourself an option in the editing room you're going to stay there to get it and you're going to dictate to the audience where you're looking when you're like and you never tap them out of it by making a cut you keep it all smooth in one thing so that it stays sort of meditative and you're in it yes exactly and i
该死，我知道我该怎么剪辑，我根本不在乎。好吧，我觉得这真的很重要。你想成为……对你来说。是的，长镜头，一镜到底非常适合这一点，对吧？你经常用那个，对吧？你在剪辑室里甚至不给自己选择的余地，你坚持要拍到那个镜头，你通过这种方式告诉观众他们应该看哪里，而且你从不通过剪辑让他们出戏，你让一切保持流畅，这样它就保持了一种冥想的状态，你沉浸在其中。是的，完全正确，而且我
think every film demands different things so not all the films needs to be that way i think again i think i learned i learned it uh to do that by by necessity in birdman that was the one that radically i knew that i i wanted to make this as an esp experience, right? It was all tied together and I wanted that the people feel in the head of Michael Keaton and it was a radical point of view of one single moment that was, again, shifting in time, but I want the people to be in his head. So I designed the whole shooting based on one single shot, obviously with stitches,
认为每部电影都有不同的需求，所以并非所有电影都需要那样。我想我再次学到了，我是出于必要在《鸟人》中那样做的，那部电影从根本上让我知道，我想把它做成一种体验，对吧？一切都紧密相连，我希望人们能感受到迈克尔·基顿的内心，这是一个单一时刻的激进视角，虽然时间在变，但我希望人们能进入他的大脑。所以我设计了整个拍摄过程，基于一个单一镜头，当然中间有缝合，
but that was a radical thing. Yeah, it was mind-blowing. Did Sam Mendes or Roger Dinkins come to you and talk to you about some of the tricks before they did 1917? No, I think Sam and Roy are masters. They know exactly what they did in 1917. I think it's something that, again,
但这确实是一件激进的事情。是的，太令人震撼了。萨姆·门德斯或罗杰·狄金斯在拍《1917》之前有没有找你谈过一些技巧？不，我认为萨姆和罗杰是大师。他们非常清楚自己在《1917》中做了什么。我认为这再次说明，
I think it's the demand of the film, but it's very fun. I just find, too, that I agree with you when you were saying about coverage, right? To be covering yourself all the time is not healthy because then there is no... I like when there is limits, no? Like principle, not rules,
我认为这是电影的需求，但这很有趣。我只是觉得，我也同意你关于覆盖镜头的说法，对吧？一直给自己留后路是不健康的，因为那样就没有……我喜欢有限制的时候，不是吗？就像原则，而不是规则，
because I don't like to use rules, but principle. And if the principle of the film has a limit or a frame or borders, I think it's much more fun work that way. And you say, okay, this is going to be the principle and the design of this film.
因为我不喜欢使用规则，而是原则。如果电影的原则有某种限制、框架或边界，我认为那样工作会更有趣。你说，好吧，这就是这部电影的原则和设计。
And then you stick with that. It forces you to explore whatever rules or principles you set up. I think everybody go into that and it's much set up, I think everybody go into that and it's much more exciting, I think. I would imagine after winning or receiving the Academy Award back to back, I would imagine the pressure on you going forward
然后你坚持这一点。它迫使你去探索你设定的任何规则或原则。我认为每个人都会投入其中，这更令人兴奋。我想象在连续获得奥斯卡奖之后，我能想象你未来的压力
or just sort of the expectations, like you know eyes are going to be on you. Does it limit the kind of swing you want to take going forward? You know, it must be tough. Yeah, I think, yes, it's true. It's true that the expectations always, you know, play against you in some way. But at the same time, it's challenging.
或者某种期望，你知道，大家的目光都会盯着你。这会限制你未来想要尝试的风格吗？你知道，这一定很难。是的，我想，是的，这是真的。期望在某种程度上总是对你不利，这是真的。但与此同时，这也是一种挑战。
After The Revenant, something that I really appreciate was that i took um a time to do a virtual reality installation that i have never done that was called carne arena yeah and it was a radical that was a very radical point of view because i put you a headset and then i put you in a in a in a in a space a big space with with um, and you were barefoot. And it was about immigrants crossing the border in the desert at dawn. And you were sensorially feeling the air of the helicopter coming. So you were walking, and basically you become the camera.
在《荒野猎人》之后，我非常感激的一件事是我花时间做了一个我从未做过的虚拟现实装置，叫《肉与沙》。是的，那是一个非常激进的视角，因为我给你戴上头显，然后把你放在一个大空间里，而且你是赤脚的。它是关于移民在黎明时分穿越沙漠越过边境的故事。你能在感官上感受到直升机靠近时的气流。所以你在走动，基本上你变成了摄像机。
So you were a ghost floating into these 14 characters being trapped by the officers in the border. And it was very, very beautiful and very emotional because suddenly, you know, I broke the dictatorship of the frame, let's put it that way. So instead to be a hole that you see a fragment of reality, you were basically navigating and walking 360 degrees, walking with these guys.
所以你是一个幽灵，漂浮在被边境官员困住的这14个角色中间。这非常非常美丽且感人，因为突然间，你知道，我打破了框架的独裁，可以这么说。所以，你看到的不再是一个现实片段的洞，你基本上是在360度导航和行走，与这些人同行。
Virtual reality, right? You could turn around and look. Yeah, exactly. And it was an incredible experience experience because it's everything that cinema is not. So I mean, these literally, you become the camera, you become the character, and then the police officer was pointing at you, you know, so wherever you move, you were really being threatened. So you become those guys in a radical way and physically your body was present there and feeling the details about it so very much i think was a big important thing for me to make this actually film you know alejandro
虚拟现实，对吧？你可以转身看。是的，完全正确。这是一次不可思议的体验，因为它是一切电影所不是的东西。所以我的意思是，这些字面上，你变成了摄像机，你变成了角色，然后警察指着你，你知道，所以无论你走到哪里，你真的受到了威胁。所以你以一种激进的方式变成了那些人，你的身体在物理上出现在那里，感受着其中的细节，所以我认为这对制作这部电影来说是非常重要的一件事，你知道，亚历杭德罗。
tell me a bit a little bit about your the impetus of doing something like that because your experience as a guy who's a filmmaker uh who who is from mexico who grew up in Mexico City, I'm assuming, yeah? Yeah. And then to make a film about this migration of people crossing, you know, the desert and doing that,
告诉我一点关于你做这件事的动力，因为你作为一个电影制作人的经验，一个来自墨西哥，在墨西哥城长大的人，我假设是这样，对吧？是的。然后去拍一部关于人们越过沙漠迁徙的电影，做这件事，
what is your relationship from that side of that perspective? You know, because, you know, we're fed all sorts of different narratives here about immigration
你从那个角度来看，你的关系是什么？你知道，因为我们在这里被灌输了各种关于移民的不同叙事，
and people, you know, migrating north across the border and blah, blah, blah. From where you are physically, what is that perspective shift? What is your, you know, obviously you were driven to make a film and it's sort of a film experience about it. Where does that land with you? Where does that sit with you, that dynamic of this sort of migration of people?
以及人们向北越过边境迁徙等等。从你所处的物理位置来看，那种视角转换是什么？你的，你知道，显然你被驱使去拍一部电影，这是一种关于它的电影体验。这对你来说意味着什么？这种人口迁徙的动态对你来说处于什么位置？
Well, I think in L.A. where I live now and I have been living here, there's almost like 5 million Mexicans, right? And for that project, I interviewed like more than 500 immigrants with incredible, you know, heartbreaking stories. Wow. Yeah. with incredible, you know, heartbreaking stories. Wow. Yeah. There was a mom that crossed seven times to bring one by one of her daughters. And it took her 20 years working as a maid, getting money little by little to go back and then turn back.
嗯，我认为在我现在居住的洛杉矶，有近500万墨西哥人，对吧？为了那个项目，我采访了500多名移民，他们有着令人难以置信的、令人心碎的故事。哇。是的。有一位母亲为了把女儿们一个接一个地带过来，穿越了七次边境。她花了20年时间做女佣，一点一点攒钱，回去然后再回来。
And the way these guys abused them, like the coyotes that charged them a lot of money, and then they left them even in the other side of the border and making them believe that they are in the United States and the way they are treated. And then the most heartbreaking kind of thing is the kids that have been taking care of them here for, you know, when they are three, four years and they don't know they are not citizens, that they don't belong to nothing. And that's the real battle, you know, that suddenly they realize at 18 that they don't have any rights, that they don't have a future.
那些人虐待她们的方式，比如向她们收取巨额费用的蛇头，然后把她们扔在边境的另一边，让她们以为自己在美国，以及她们受到的对待。最令人心碎的是那些在这里被照顾了三四年的孩子，当他们三四岁时，他们不知道自己不是公民，他们不属于任何地方。这就是真正的战斗，你知道，他们突然在18岁时意识到自己没有任何权利，没有任何未来。
And they don't know even how to speak Spanish. And there's no way for them to go back because there is no other territory. So those stories for me has been always close to me. And obviously, you know, socially, I know many of these stories. And so I feel very close, even when my circumstances have been completely different. I have been incredibly lucky, supported, privileged. But anyway, that doesn't mean that I'm not feeling kind of close to these stories. And yeah, I mean, for me, it's just the situation of so many millions of people. It's really hard. It so many millions of people.
他们甚至不知道怎么说西班牙语。他们没有办法回去，因为那里已经没有其他领土了。所以这些故事对我来说一直很亲近。显然，在社会层面上，我知道很多这样的故事。所以我感到非常亲近，即使我的处境完全不同。我非常幸运，得到了支持，享有特权。但无论如何，这并不意味着我不觉得与这些故事很亲近。是的，我的意思是，对我来说，这只是数百万人的处境。这真的很难。
It's really hard. It's very hard to understand. That's actually a nice segue into a question that I've had, which is, you know, and forgive me because I'm asking because I don't know. I'm uneducated in this area. But, you know, growing up... What weighs more, a bag of Skittles or a bag of M&M's? Sorry. But, you know, growing up in Chicago and in America,
这真的很难。这很难理解。这实际上是一个很好的过渡，引出了我一直有的一个问题，你知道，请原谅我，因为我问是因为我不知道。我在这个领域受教育程度不高。但是，你知道，成长过程中……一袋彩虹糖和一袋M&M巧克力豆哪个更重？抱歉。但是，你知道，在芝加哥和美国长大，
we have these tremendous resources to, you know, when I grew up in Chicago, I was like, oh, Hollywood. And, you know, there's universities and colleges now where your major can be filmmaking and everything in this country. And there are programs in other countries too. But what was it like for you as a kid? What kind of resources did you have? What kind of anything did you have what kind of
我们有巨大的资源，你知道，当我在芝加哥长大时，我想，哦，好莱坞。而且，现在有大学和学院，你的专业可以是电影制作，这个国家的一切都是如此。其他国家也有项目。但你小时候是什么样的？你有什么样的资源？你有什么样的东西，
anything did you have growing up to know that this is your path to prepare for this career you mean yeah no no you can you cannot prepare i i think that i never thought that i will be living here you know our plan was after amores perros my wife and i decided to come here for one year the situation in mexico I'm from a generation that in our country there was only six to seven films being made a year, so there was no actual, you know, something that as filmmakers, Alfonso Cuarón or Guillermo del Toro or Chivo Lubezki,
你成长过程中有什么东西让你知道这是你的道路，为你准备这个职业，你是这个意思吗？是的，不，不，你无法准备。我认为我从未想过我会住在这里，你知道，我们的计划是在《爱情是狗娘》之后，我和我妻子决定来这里一年。墨西哥的情况，我来自这样一代人，在我们的国家，一年只拍六到七部电影，所以没有实际的，你知道，作为电影制作人，阿方索·卡隆、吉尔莫·德尔·托罗或奇沃·卢贝兹基那样的事情。
we had to come to look for something that we want to pursue, which was a filmmaker career, and our country cannot provide that at that time. Security not very very good uh as it is even now so when you become a public figure it's a little challenging so in a way we have two little kids and we said well let's go one year and then 21 years has passed and it feels that it happened in one week that's part of the and that's that's what the film is kind of, that was the reason I made this film, like to clean the closet emotionally
我们必须去寻找我们想要追求的东西，那就是电影制作人的职业生涯，而我们的国家在当时无法提供这些。安全状况也不是很好，即使是现在也一样，所以当你成为公众人物时，这有点挑战性。从某种意义上说，我们有两个小孩，我们说，好吧，去一年吧，结果21年过去了，感觉就像过了一周一样，这就是电影的一部分，这也是我制作这部电影的原因，就像是在情感上清理壁橱。
and just to put things in order, you know? And I think you don't have to leave, you're from Toronto, right? A lot of friends, American friends that are from little towns in the South and they are living here. And when they return, all their friends or their families
只是为了把事情整理好，你知道吗？我认为你不必离开，你是多伦多来的，对吧？很多朋友，来自南方小镇的美国朋友，他们住在这里。当他们回去时，他们所有的朋友或家人
stays one way that they have been evolving and transforming. And it's a huge change. I mean, that's another battle. You don't have to leave your country to feel that your past is not belonging to you anymore. Or that was another person kind of thing. Right. Yeah.
都保持着他们进化和转变的方式。这是一个巨大的变化。我的意思是，那是另一场战斗。你不必离开你的国家也会觉得你的过去不再属于你了。或者那已经是另一个人了。对。是的。
Talk to me about music. So you started with working working radio dj and interviewing some incredible people but you've also done a little bit of scoring for films before you became a director yes and then yes i also want you to talk about your the the the strategy for doing the music in birdman where the camera would actually show the drummer every once in a while. It's so inventive and so bold and so exciting for an audience member and that you're able to pull all those big swings off somehow. Just talk to me about music and film and how you enjoy writing music for films as well you know when I when I in a way writing and developing and thinking about a film as I told you I so important for me to hear the film yeah listen to the beat the rhythm and how it sounds so I always
跟我谈谈音乐吧。你最初是做电台DJ的，采访过一些了不起的人，但在成为导演之前，你也为电影做过一点配乐，是的，然后是的，我还想让你谈谈你在《鸟人》中处理音乐的策略，摄像机实际上偶尔会拍到鼓手。这对观众来说太有创意、太大胆、太令人兴奋了，你竟然能以某种方式完成所有这些大胆的尝试。跟我谈谈音乐和电影，以及你如何享受为电影创作音乐，你知道，当我以某种方式创作、开发和思考一部电影时，正如我告诉你的，对我来说，听到这部电影非常重要，是的，听听节拍、节奏以及它的声音，所以我总是
felt that you know I was very clear with Amores Perros that it sounds like sticky fingers of the Rolling Stones for for example, that album. It was that sound that I wanted to portray. And then there are some times I listen to one album only when I'm 21 grams, I hear to Pat Metheny album that I love about, it was in a spiritual film. Well, there was something attached to some song that suddenly I get stuck to that. And are you saying that the album you listen to
觉得，你知道，我对《爱情是狗娘》非常清楚，它听起来就像滚石乐队的《Sticky Fingers》，例如那张专辑。那就是我想要描绘的声音。有时我只听一张专辑，当我做《21克》时，我听我喜欢的帕特·梅西尼的专辑，那是在一部精神电影中。好吧，有些东西附着在某首歌上，我突然就迷上了它。你是说你听的专辑
or the songs you listen to creates imagery in your head? Is that what you're saying? It just creates a mood, you know? I think it's something that suddenly the sound of an album can portray you a mood and the sound in a way, there's something that makes me feel close to the pace, to the spirit of the film. And for me, an embedment, for example,
或者你听的歌会在你脑海中创造意象吗？你是这个意思吗？它只是创造了一种情绪，你知道吗？我认为有些东西突然间，一张专辑的声音可以为你描绘一种情绪，而这种声音在某种程度上，有些东西让我感到接近电影的节奏和精神。对我来说，在《鸟人》中，例如，
I knew that I need drums because I knew that I wanted to make a one take by that reason of the radical point of view. So being a comedy, I said, oh shit. I mean, comedy, as they said, is made in cuts, right? And it's like the rhythm, it's creating the editing room. I knew that I will not have that opportunity. So I needed a rhythm.
我知道我需要鼓声，因为我知道我想因为激进的观点而做一个长镜头。所以作为一部喜剧，我说，哦，该死。我的意思是，正如他们所说，喜剧是由剪辑组成的，对吧？就像节奏一样，它是在剪辑室里创造的。我知道我不会有那个机会。所以我需要一个节奏。
I need something. Or like a rim shot, right? It sort of ends a joke or ends a scene and carries you into the next one. Exactly. And then I have been very lucky because my first four films, I worked with Gustavo Santaolalla,
我需要一些东西。或者像边鼓敲击，对吧？它结束了一个笑话或结束了一个场景，并把你带入下一个场景。完全正确。而且我一直很幸运，因为我的前四部电影，我和古斯塔沃·桑塔欧拉拉合作，
which is an incredible musician. And he do like minimalistic things, you know, with a couple of guitar moves and things, he just create again. I like to use very minimalistic music in that sense. And so every experience has been different. Then in Revenant, I worked with Ryuichi Sakamoto, that you cannot ask for more than the master Sakamoto
他是一位了不起的音乐家。他做那种极简主义的东西，你知道，用几个吉他动作和东西，他再次创造了。我喜欢在那种意义上使用非常极简主义的音乐。所以每一次经历都是不同的。然后在《荒野猎人》中，我和坂本龙一合作，你不能要求比大师坂本更多了
and it was another experience. And then in this one I did it with Bryce Dessner, you know, which is incredible musician. From the National? From the National, yeah. Bryce is just so eclectic. I mean, he do classical music, he do jazz, he do everything. So I was able to work with him this time and it was fantastic. And you do have all those different sounds in it.
那是另一种经历。然后在这部电影中，我和布莱斯·德斯纳合作，你知道，他是一位了不起的音乐家。来自The National乐队？来自The National，是的。布莱斯真是太折衷了。我的意思是，他做古典音乐，他做爵士乐，他做一切。所以我这次能和他一起工作，这太棒了。你确实在里面有所有那些不同的声音。
Bryce is a super talented guy. He and those guys just did that. Well, my buddy Bon Iver just did a collab with those guys, but Jason doesn't. Do you like Bon Iver at all, Alejandro? I love Bon Iver. Oh, no kidding. Now I do. Keep going. Now I do. Keep going. Of course you do. That guy is genius. Oh, really? Bryce has just worked with Tom York, too. Yeah.
布莱斯是一个超级有才华的人。他和那些家伙刚刚做到了。好吧，我的哥们Bon Iver刚刚和那些家伙合作了，但杰森没有。你喜欢Bon Iver吗，亚历杭德罗？我爱Bon Iver。哦，别开玩笑了。现在我喜欢了。继续。现在我喜欢了。继续。你当然喜欢。那家伙是天才。哦，真的吗？布莱斯也刚刚和汤姆·约克合作过。是的。
Or even with Steve Reich, you know? So he's in all these kind of genres, you know? He's crazy. Thank you, Alejandro. Thank you, Jason. Why? Who don't like Bon Iver? I just don't like the name. Jason's made fun of it for like two years
甚至和史蒂夫·莱奇一起，你知道吗？所以他涉足所有这些流派，你知道吗？他太疯狂了。谢谢你，亚历杭德罗。谢谢你，杰森。为什么？谁不喜欢Bon Iver？我只是不喜欢这个名字。杰森已经拿它开玩笑了两年了
because he doesn't... Now that he thinks the cool kids like him, he's going to be all over it. No, I'm on. You said Tom York, I'm in. Oh my God. I'm rage quitting this episode. We'll be right back. In-laws, love them or hate them, you're pretty much stuck with them. And when you're a ruler in the Middle Ages, that can be a serious problem.
因为他不……现在他认为酷孩子们喜欢他，他就会到处宣扬。不，我加入了。你说汤姆·约克，我加入了。天哪。我要愤怒地退出这一集。我们马上回来。姻亲，爱他们或恨他们，你基本上都被他们困住了。当你是一个中世纪的统治者时，那可能是一个严重的问题。
It might even land you dead. a serious problem. It might even land you dead. I'm Dan Jones, and on season four of This Is History, I'm telling the story of England's weirdest king, Henry III. He's in way over his head, and he's surrounded by bloodthirsty relatives with their eyes on his throne. To listen, search This Is History, and follow wherever you get your podcasts. you get your podcasts. Hello, I am Alice Levine and I am one of the hosts of Wondery's podcast, British Scandal. On our latest series, The Race to Ruin, we tell the story of a British man who took part in the first ever round the world sailing race. Good on him, I hear you say.
它甚至可能让你送命。一个严重的问题。它甚至可能让你送命。我是丹·琼斯，在《这就是历史》第四季中，我讲述了英国最奇怪的国王亨利三世的故事。他完全无法应付，周围都是盯着他王位的嗜血亲戚。要收听，请搜索《这就是历史》，并在你获取播客的任何地方关注。你获取播客的地方。你好，我是爱丽丝·莱文，我是Wondery播客《英国丑闻》的主持人之一。在我们最新的系列《毁灭竞赛》中，我们讲述了一个英国男人的故事，他参加了有史以来第一次环球航行比赛。我听到你说，他做得好。
But there is a problem, as there always is in this show. The man in question hadn't actually sailed before oh and his boat wasn't seaworthy oh and also tiny little detail almost didn't mention it he bet his family home on making it to the finish line what ensued was one of the most complex cheating plots in british sporting history to find out the full story follow british scandal wherever you listen to podcasts or listen early and ad free-free on Wondery Plus on Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. Beneath the veneer of the everyday lurks the realm of the spy. It's a dank, murky world full of dark corners, sinister motives and corroded morals.
但有一个问题，就像这个节目中总是有问题一样。那个男人之前并没有真正航行过，哦，他的船也不适航，哦，还有一个微小的细节，差点没提，他把他的家庭住宅赌在了到达终点线上。随之而来的是英国体育史上最复杂的作弊阴谋之一。要了解完整的故事，请在任何你收听播客的地方关注《英国丑闻》，或者在Apple Podcasts或Wondery应用程序上提前收听无广告版本。在日常生活的表象之下潜伏着间谍的领域。这是一个潮湿、阴暗的世界，充满了黑暗的角落、险恶的动机和腐烂的道德。
A place of paranoia and infiltration, sabotage and manipulation. From Wondery, I'm Indra Varma. This is The Spy Who, a show that takes you inside the twilight realm of espionage. These are true stories you were never meant to hear, with secret operatives playing to very different rules. And now, back to the show. Let me stop you at Revenant for one second. No, the Revenant's good. And now, back to the show. Let me stop you at Revenant for one second. No, the Revenant's good. I apologize if you've answered this question on this subject before. I'm sure you have because I don't know if a sequence will ever be made that is more –
一个充满偏执和渗透、破坏和操纵的地方。来自Wondery，我是因陀罗·瓦尔马。这是《间谍是谁》，一个带你进入间谍活动暮光领域的节目。这些是你从未听说过的真实故事，秘密特工按照非常不同的规则行事。现在，回到节目。让我打断你一下，关于《荒野猎人》。不，《荒野猎人》很好。现在，回到节目。让我打断你一下，关于《荒野猎人》。不，《荒野猎人》很好。如果在这个主题上你之前回答过这个问题，我道歉。我相信你回答过，因为我不知道是否还会制作出比这更——
The bear fight is something that when when i was watching it i i was i knew it wasn't real obviously uh because uh leo takes a lot of risks but that one would be too much um and so i'm so i'm studying the the i saw in a big theater too and i'm looking for where is where's the cut where's the where's the special effect where how are they doing and I could not see it not once and and to your point about one take it was a one-er was it not it was all so why would you in something so technically difficult as that sequence why would you choose to to really make it even more tough by making it one take? How did you come to that decision?
熊的打斗是这样的，当我观看它时，我知道它显然不是真的，因为莱昂纳多冒了很多风险，但那一个会太多了，所以我正在研究，我在一个大剧院里也看到了，我在寻找剪辑在哪里，特效在哪里，他们是怎么做的，我一次也看不出来，关于长镜头，那是一个长镜头，不是吗？这一切都是，所以为什么在像那个序列这样技术上如此困难的事情中，你会选择通过制作一个长镜头来让它变得更加艰难？你是怎么做出那个决定的？
I did a lot of research about the bear attacks and the description of it. There's a book, actually, of people that survived. It's a weird book with like 120 cases of people that have survived. I'd love to read that. Oh, my God. Sean's seen over 120 bear fights over a long weekend once during Pride.
我做了很多关于熊袭击和描述的研究。实际上有一本书，是关于幸存者的人的。那是一本奇怪的书，有大约120个幸存者案例。我很想读那本书。天哪。肖恩在骄傲节期间的一个长周末里见过120多场熊打斗。
I'm Santa Monica. So, when I was reading these attacks, normally it was about the cops. You know, when you cross and there are cops, they're closed. Then you know that you are screwed.
我在圣莫尼卡。所以，当我阅读这些袭击时，通常是关于警察的。你知道，当你穿过时，有警察，他们关门了。那么你就知道你完蛋了。
You know that you are in danger. And the description of the people, the way they felt it, the way they remembered, the way they felt, again, they experienced in a point of view of them. And it was shocking to see, you know, the fear, everything. So I said, I would love instead to rely on the cutting and in the objective point of view of a filmmaker and a camera seeing things and putting pieces together I would like again to
你知道你处于危险之中。人们的描述，他们感受到的方式，他们记忆的方式，他们感受的方式，再次，他们以他们的观点体验了它。看到恐惧、一切，真是令人震惊。所以我说，我宁愿不依赖剪辑和电影制作人和摄像机观察事物并将碎片放在一起的客观观点，我想再次
observe and and just to be present as if I'm witnesses that in real time which will be the most terrifying thing how somebody's been the war yeah and i remember um with berners herzo you remember his documentary and uh and that moment that bernard is sitting with the headphones and he's hearing how this guy was the war and how these guys were the war by this and i said bernard what did you hear he said alejandro you don't want toandro, you don't want to hear. He said, you don't want to tell me what I heard. And what he described to me, we were in a dinner. It was so terrifying what he described to me about that, you know, the bears, in a way, first pull out your skin, and little by little,
观察并只是在场，就好像我是实时见证者一样，这将是最可怕的事情，某人是如何经历战争的，是的，我记得嗯，和沃纳·赫尔佐格，你记得他的纪录片，嗯，那一刻沃纳戴着耳机坐着，他听着这个家伙是如何经历战争的，以及这些人是如何经历战争的，我说沃纳你听到了什么，他说亚历杭德罗，你不想听。他说，你不想告诉我我听到了什么。他向我描述的内容，我们在吃晚饭。他向我描述的关于那个的事情太可怕了，你知道，熊，在某种程度上，首先拔掉你的皮肤，一点一点地，
what I'm saying, they don't kill you immediately. They want warm meat, and so they keep you alive, and they are taking your skin off little by little so they are deboring you in pieces anyway the descriptions that i have were so terrified that i want the audience to for a moment try to put the audience in witnessing something so horrific like that so that's why i decided to do that it worked who to so so when you when you when you decided that this is what you would love to do, that's your ambition,
我所说的是，他们不会立即杀死你。他们想要温暖的肉，所以他们让你活着，他们一点一点地剥掉你的皮肤，所以他们无论如何都在一点一点地吞噬你，我得到的描述太可怕了，以至于我想让观众暂时尝试让观众见证如此恐怖的事情，这就是为什么我决定这样做，它奏效了，谁，所以当你决定这就是你想要做的，那是你的野心，
but then you've got to check it with who? Your visual effects supervisor or Chivo? Or who told you that this was going to be possible? Because I don't think anyone's ever seen anything like that before, and it'd be tough to see it again. I don't know if everyone's ever going to be able to do that again, but who told you that was technically possible to do? Well, I think that it's possible because I think the visual effects and the CEI has
但你必须和谁核对？你的视觉特效主管还是奇沃？或者谁告诉你这是可能的？因为我不认为有人以前见过这样的事情，而且很难再看到它。我不知道是否每个人都能再做一次，但谁告诉你这在技术上是可能的？好吧，我认为这是可能的，因为我认为视觉特效和CGI已经
arrived to a point that I was really, you know, worried that it will look good. But I have to credit here ILM. I think they did an amazing job by creating this incredible, believable bear with all the hair. So now the technology allows you to create something like that, but you have to just prepare it very well. You know, you have to really have a good idea how you want to make it. So we rehearsed for weeks. first of all, the blocking, and then obviously study and analyzing how really a bear will hit you, will scratch you, will do it. So we have some expertise about that.
达到了一个地步，我真的很担心它看起来会很好。但我必须在这里归功于ILM。我认为他们通过创造这只令人难以置信、可信的、带有所有毛发的熊做得非常出色。所以现在技术允许你创造这样的东西，但你必须准备得非常好。你知道，你必须真正有一个很好的想法，你想怎么做。所以我们排练了几个星期。首先，走位，然后显然研究和分析熊真的会如何打你，会如何抓你，会如何做。所以我们对此有一些专业知识。
And what I read was I was applying to what it was actually factual of the attacks of the bear. So then with Leo, we started rehearsing with a trainer, with a stunt that will be doing kind of the bear character. And we were saying, okay, now he will do that. Then he will grab it by the leg. He will drag him here. And then she and I started designing the camera move to understand what.
我读到的是我正在应用到熊袭击的实际事实。所以然后和莱昂纳多一起，我们开始和一个训练师、一个将扮演熊角色的特技演员排练。我们说，好吧，现在他会那样做。然后他会抓住腿。他会把他拖到这里。然后她和我开始设计摄像机移动以了解什么。
So little by little, we were kind of shaping the moments. And then we knew that we have to make it in one shot. So we start rehearsing with the camera, with the stunts, with Leo. And then we knew that we will have to use harnesses, you know, to... Yeah, the harnesses, the wires. He was tied up to a bunch of wires.
所以一点一点地，我们正在塑造这些时刻。然后我们知道我们必须在一个镜头中完成它。所以我们开始和摄像机、特技演员、莱昂纳多一起排练。然后我们知道我们将不得不使用安全带，你知道，去……是的，安全带，电线。他被绑在一堆电线上。
It had to pull them all over the place as a bear would easily pull and push and throw him all over the place. Yeah. It was very challenging because we shot that actually in the middle of the woods, you know, in Vancouver. So in a way it was, you know, we have to prepare the whole territory, the arnés, the camera didn't have to cross with that.
它必须把他拉得到处都是，就像熊会轻易地拉、推并把他扔得到处都是一样。是的。这非常有挑战性，因为我们实际上是在温哥华森林中间拍摄的。所以从某种意义上说，你知道，我们必须准备整个领土，安全带，摄像机不必与那个交叉。
So again, that's a boring and technical thing that I don't think is so difficult. I just think you need to have a clear idea of what you want to achieve, and then everything almost is possible. You have to have the bare necessities. Oh, very nice. Bare necessities, Sean says. He loves a pun. Talk to me, Alejandro, about your relationship with your
所以再次，那是一件无聊且技术性的事情，我不认为这有多难。我只是认为你需要对你想实现的目标有一个清晰的想法，然后几乎一切皆有可能。你必须拥有最基本的需求。哦，非常好。最基本的需求，肖恩说。他喜欢双关语。跟我谈谈，亚历杭德罗，关于你和你的关系
collaborator, writer, Guillermo, and I don't want to say his name wrong. Arriaga. Arriaga. Yeah. Tell me a little bit about that relationship. You guys worked together on a lot of films, yeah? Yeah, we did three films together. That was this trilogy that was, we were exploring, you know,
合作者、作家吉列尔莫，我不想把他的名字说错。阿里亚加。阿里亚加。是的。告诉我一点关于那种关系。你们一起拍了很多电影，对吧？是的，我们一起拍了三部电影。那是那个三部曲，我们正在探索，你知道，
the possibilities of structures and how, you know, people, one event in a way was affecting different lives in a different way. Sure. Or in Babel, that was extreme, you know? Is Guillermo the cinematographer or writer? The writer.
结构的各种可能性，以及你知道，人们，一个事件在某种程度上是如何以不同的方式影响不同的生活的。当然。或者在《通天塔》中，那是极端的，你知道吗？吉列尔莫是摄影师还是作家？作家。
Sorry, the writer. But what I was sort of asking more, yeah, I know, right, you guys were creating this incredible trilogy, but the relationship that you guys have and how that changes over writing three films together and that process of your relationship and what that, you know, for instance, my relationship with, I'm going to mention Chappie again, my
抱歉，作家。但我更多是在问，是的，我知道，对吧，你们在创造这个令人难以置信的三部曲，但你们之间的关系，以及在共同编写三部电影的过程中它是如何变化的，以及你们关系的过程，以及那，你知道，例如，我和，我要再次提到查皮，我的
guy that I write with whom I love and I adore. And I have such a deep connection with him because we spend so much time writing in a room together and what that relationship, anyway, you guys have written these great films together. Talk to me about your personal relationship and how it has sort of brought you guys together or how it's changed in, I don't know. I think we met in 1997. So we start developing like short stories
我一起写作的家伙，我爱他，我崇拜他。我和他有如此深厚的联系，因为我们花了很多时间在一个房间里一起写作，那种关系，无论如何，你们一起写了这些伟大的电影。跟我谈谈你们的个人关系，以及它是如何把你们聚在一起的，或者它是如何改变的，我不知道。我想我们是在1997年认识的。所以我们开始开发像短篇小说一样的东西
that end up being Amores Perros first. And it was a great time for both of us. You know what I mean? We were sharing the same kind of sensibility. Writers, Faulkner was kind of an inspiration about his rawness, raw and humanity and things. So in a way, we were sharing a lot of things during those years you
最终成为了《爱情是狗娘》。对我们俩来说，那是一段美好的时光。你知道我的意思吗？我们分享着同样的敏感度。作家，福克纳关于他的原始、原始和人性以及事物是一种灵感。所以从某种意义上说，在那些年里，我们分享了很多东西，你知道
know and that was very very profound because when you share it's very hard to find a collaborator that you share points of view you know our sense it sensibilities and sources of inspiration so it was great and i think that after the the last film you know I think it was great because I was a little bit burned out about the structure and the fracture narratives, and I wanted to make a film about one single character, which for me was super unconventional, very difficult. So then it ends, you know, any creative relation sometimes finds an end or a transformation,
那是非常非常深刻的，因为当你分享时，很难找到一个你分享观点的合作者，你知道，我们的感官、敏感度和灵感来源，所以这很棒，我认为在最后一部电影之后，你知道，我认为这很棒，因为我对结构和断裂的叙事有点精疲力竭，我想拍一部关于一个单一角色的电影，这对我来说是非常规的，非常困难。所以然后它结束了，你知道，任何创造性的关系有时都会找到终点或转变，
and then you need to find yourself. And then the next film in Beautiful, I just found two co-writers that were fantastic, which is Nicolás Jacobone, which is the one who I have been collaborating in this last film and Armando Bo. So anyway, I think for me, it was a way to be evolving and transforming.
然后你需要找到你自己。然后下一部电影《美错》，我只是找到了两个非常棒的联合编剧，尼古拉斯·贾科博内，他是我在最后一部电影中一直合作的人，还有阿曼多·博。所以无论如何，我认为对我来说，这是一种进化和转变的方式。
And that relation in a way was very, very, very productive by having three films and was was great you know was great all right lastly Alejandro we've been heaping so much praise on you about how good you are at making movies what are you terrible at are you you really bad at anything uh how about sing singing or dancing or sports or anything like that what what are you worst at I I am so bad in almost everything, let me tell you. I don't believe it. The only thing that I try to attempt to do my best is to make films,
那种关系在某种程度上是非常非常非常有成效的，通过拥有三部电影，而且很棒，你知道，很棒。好吧，最后，亚历杭德罗，我们一直在称赞你拍电影有多好，你有什么不擅长的吗？你真的有什么非常糟糕的吗？嗯，唱歌、跳舞或运动之类的怎么样？你最不擅长什么？我几乎在所有事情上都很糟糕，让我告诉你。我不相信。我唯一尝试尽力做的事情就是拍电影，
but I'm so bad. My hands are really clumsy, let me put it that way. I cannot draw, for example. I cannot draw an apple. So you don't storyboard yourself. No, I don't storyboard myself. I would love to, but I can't. And then i wanted
但我太糟糕了。我的手真的很笨拙，让我这样说吧。例如，我不会画画。我连苹果都画不出来。所以你不自己画分镜。不，我不自己画分镜。我很想，但我做不到。然后我想
to be a musician and i have terrible fingers to play the guitar so i'm absolutely bad with my with my hands are clumsy so in a way the only thing that i could possibly do is what i do i think that's why i do what i do well please keep doing it you just you're you're one of our one of our greatest ever and uh i I love watching everything you do. You don't need to be good at anything. You're very kind. You make incredible films. I'm so glad that you enjoy Bardo.
成为一名音乐家，但我弹吉他的手指太糟糕了，所以我绝对很糟糕，我的手很笨拙，所以从某种意义上说，我唯一可能做的事情就是我所做的，我想这就是为什么我做我所做的事情。好吧，请继续做下去。你只是，你是我们有史以来最伟大的人之一，而且我喜欢看你做的一切。你不需要擅长任何事情。你太客气了。你拍了令人难以置信的电影。我很高兴你喜欢《诗人》。
I really hope that you two guys see it, and I'm very happy. Bardo is just— I'm going to see it this weekend. I can't wait. Let's go see it in a movie theater. I want to go with you and see it in a theater this time. It's just stunning. Everybody should rush out. I want to go with you and see it in a theater this time. I will totally do that. It's just stunning. Everybody should rush out.
我真的希望你们两个能看到它，我很高兴。《诗人》只是——我这个周末要去看它。我等不及了。我们去电影院看吧。这次我想和你一起去电影院看。它太令人惊叹了。每个人都应该冲出去。这次我想和你一起去电影院看。我绝对会那样做。它太令人惊叹了。每个人都应该冲出去。
I just want to tell you something. I think when you see it, guys, don't try to demand logic on it, okay? I mean, turn off your co-pilot of rational demandings and just let yourself go. Oh, I don't. I wake up and go to bed that way. And it goes by in about 10 minutes. It is one of the fastest watches i've ever seen too it's just it you just get transported it's it's great i can't wait uh thank
我只是想告诉你一件事。我想当你们看到它时，伙计们，不要试图要求逻辑，好吗？我的意思是，关掉你理性的副驾驶，让自己走吧。哦，我不会。我醒来和睡觉都是那样。它在大约10分钟内就过去了。这也是我看过的最快的电影之一，它只是，你只是被传送了，它很棒，我等不及了，谢谢
you so much for being with us today and uh no please thank you very much guys to include me in this in this in this podcast it's fantastic to talk to you and thank you very much thank you thank you thank you enjoy your day. Bye-bye. Thank you. Ciao. Bye. Well, man, I feel cultured, bathed. Yeah. Bathed in greatness. Great guy. Well, guys, thank you for letting me vomit all over my hero there.
你今天和我们在一起，而且，不，请非常感谢你们让我参加这个播客，和你们交谈真是太棒了，非常感谢，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢，祝你今天愉快。再见。谢谢。再见。再见。好吧，伙计，我觉得很有文化，被洗礼了。是的。沐浴在伟大之中。很棒的家伙。好吧，伙计们，谢谢你们让我对我那里的英雄呕吐。
Yeah, he's great. I know. Do you think that we'll be able to cut in any of him talking for the first 20 minutes? Was I going on? Was I going on? I was in a blackout. I loved it. I loved that. That was so cool.
是的，他很棒。我知道。你认为我们能剪掉他前20分钟谈话的任何内容吗？我一直在说吗？我一直在说吗？我当时昏迷了。我喜欢它。我喜欢那个。那太酷了。
No, it was good. It was good. You were obviously like super into it and he— I mean, the guy's got more talent than— I mean, I just— He could probably— If time would allow, he could probably make three or four great movies every
不，那很好。那很好。你显然非常投入，而且他——我的意思是，这家伙有更多的天赋——我的意思是，我只是——如果时间允许，他可能每年都能拍三四部伟大的电影。
year. I know. It's just, it's pretty stunning. And what a nice person, too. Right? Super sweet and super sort of generous with, like, his process. Boy, do you see this movie, too. Yeah, he seems like a very calm, calm director, like a calm
我知道。这真是太令人惊叹了。而且也是一个很好的人，对吧？超级甜，而且对他的过程非常慷慨。伙计，你也看这部电影。是的，他看起来像一个非常冷静、冷静的导演，像一个冷静的
presence. Like, there's some directors that are like, you know, like, I would be a terrible director, calm director, like a calm presence. Like there's some directors that are like, you know, like I would be a terrible director because they're like, what's going on? And I'd freak out. But like, he's more like, hey, we're going to make this happen and everything's going to be just fine. Sean, would you do Revenant too? Sure.
存在。就像有些导演，你知道，就像，我会是一个糟糕的导演，冷静的导演，像一个冷静的存在。就像有些导演，你知道，就像我会是一个糟糕的导演，因为他们就像，发生了什么？我会吓坏的。但就像，他更像是，嘿，我们要实现这一点，一切都会好起来的。肖恩，你也会做《荒野猎人》吗？当然。
If he was like, I'm going to do Still Revan. Pending script approval. Still Revin'. Would you do a movie called Bear Attack? And the whole movie is just you. Yeah, we can film it in my bedroom. You running from Scotty. You wrestling Scotty, yeah.
如果他像，我要做《荒野猎人》。等待剧本批准。还是《荒野猎人》。你会拍一部叫《熊袭击》的电影吗？整部电影只有你。是的，我们可以在我的卧室里拍。你从斯科蒂那里跑开。你和斯科蒂摔跤，是的。
Let's be honest, that's Cub Attack. That is Cub Attack, which is a lot easier to get out of. Do you speak, but you don't speak bear, do you? You're not bilingual. Bye. Bye. Very nice. Smart.
老实说，那是《幼崽袭击》。那是《幼崽袭击》，这更容易摆脱。你会说，但你不会说熊语，对吧？你不是双语的。再见。再见。非常好。聪明。
Blast. Smart. Blast. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjarv, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Granteri. Smart Less. If you like Smart Less, you can listen early and ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus in the Wondery app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen ad-free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at wondery.com slash survey. When I say the word history, what do you think about? Horses and buggies and dust and a bunch of white dudes riding their horses and buggies in the dust?
爆炸。聪明。SmartLess是由Rob Armjarv、Bennett Barbico和Michael Granteri 100%有机和手工制作的。Smart Less。如果你喜欢Smart Less，你可以通过在Wondery应用程序或Apple Podcasts上加入Wondery Plus来立即提前收听无广告版本。Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上免费收听无广告版本。在你走之前，通过在wondery.com/survey填写简短的调查告诉我们关于你自己的信息。当我提到历史这个词时，你会想到什么？马车、灰尘，还有一群白人坐在马车里在灰尘中骑行？
Facts! Definitely not enough melanin on all those history books. But we are about to flip the script on all of that. From Wondery, this is Black History For Real. Together we'll weave Black History's most overlooked figures back into the rightful place in American culture and all over the world. Follow Black History For Real on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
事实！绝对没有足够的黑色素在所有那些历史书中。但我们即将颠覆所有这些。来自Wondery，这是《真实的黑人历史》。我们将一起把黑人历史中最被忽视的人物重新编织回他们在美洲文化和世界各地的应有地位。在Wondery应用程序或任何你获取播客的地方关注《真实的黑人历史》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。